today's episode is brought to you by
t-mobile America's best unlimited
network
a new hope through people's minds the
Empire Strikes Back challenge what you
thought a sequel could be now the last
chapter of the original trilogy takes
its place in history as the third one
Star Wars Return of the Jedi from
creative visionary George Lucas and won
Spielberg Lynch and Cronenberg passed
the cheapest director he could find
comes a film that had to live up to
impossibly high expectations and said
screw it we're making a kids movie full
of burp gags in slapstick comedy and
Boba Fett going out like Wiley coyote in
a finale
that's almost silly enough to make you
question why your identity is so tied to
a soap opera about space wizards
[Music]
that's it I'm a Trekkie now what does
God need with a starship never mind all
your favourite heroes have returned like
Luke has grown from naive farm boy to
goth Catholic priest Han who was already
so over Star Wars they had him frozen in
case he didn't bother to show up
Leia who suddenly Luke's sister no you
have well that makes this extra we're
then plus an all-new cast of memorable
characters like her salacious crumbs
kind of fun and crunk sure why not
before there was Jar Jar the object of
fans blind rage was the Ewoks a race of
cuddly creatures inspired by puppy dogs
bear cubs and toy sales who Lucas loved
so much they got two spin-off movies to
[Music]
that discerning fans hated because
there's no way the mighty empire would
struggle against a smaller poorly armed
force what do you think this is Vietnam
Afghanistan Little Bighorn the American
Revolution the Maori Ethiopia
Afghanistan again set aside a special
place in hell where Jedi special edition
that not only adds the same bad cg as
the other two but tons of crap that's
only there to remind you of the prequels
like gun guns
extra nose
[Applause]
Hayden Christensen's and the criminal
erasure of the gub-gub song an entire
generation will grow up with that awful
Jedi rocks number but never know the
brilliance of John Williams Yub nub song
for shame so return to Star Wars with
Return of the Jedi a movie that joins
Godfather 3 Terminator 3 and spider-man
3 in the tradition of man 3rd
installments that turn an epic about the
fate of the galaxy into the Skywalker
family drama cemented the kid-friendly
tone of the franchise and set up Star
Wars long-running love affair with the
plot of a new home a battle station the
emperor's new battle station the Droid
control ship star killer base death stop
we're starting our attack run is teyla
who could run out of space real fast
you know it's like poetry so if they
ride every stanza kind of rhymes with
the last one hopefully it'll work yep
it did story my MIDI coracle romance I'm
gonna bored feeling about this
Sonny Dee Williams ball sack force man
Captain phasma Sister Sister ghost dad
harmonica solo Teddy sucks been Nene and
this little guy parliament trunk atelic
and slog life star wars 3 episode 6 out
of 9 possibly 12
just a word of advice to Daisy Ridley if
you see Lucas talking to the wardrobe
department run today's episode is
brought to you by t-mobile
switch to America's best unlimited
network but I was going to tashi station
to pick up some power converters come on
it's lovely weather for a sleigh ride
together with you something ramdom Hans
Bubbe I'm your white knight could you
please not eat my bologna